tu direct est satisfait de ce que la
vita données je sais que c'est pas
franchement ce dont on rêvait au départ
qui peut se vanter d'avoir eu tout ce
qu'il voulait
qu'est ce que tu sais peut-être société
rigoles ces gens folle et fuir joue pas
avec ton cerveau mec t'as l'air de
chercher quelque chose
une troisième autorités est il ce soir
je cherche les colons
n'oubliez pas de vous amuser
dites nous votre fantasme nous vous
donne le souvenir quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe
au fait une erreur je suis un mec lambda
tu les avais cherry cola prix de l'eau
quoique j'ai tu sais ça je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé mais en sortira de là
s'inquiète
conneries
qu'est ce que tu fous c'est mon boulot
demotte mariage alors je simule très
bien l'extase conjugales
tu vas trouvé ça difficile à croire
tous ces souvenirs que tu crois
on parle vrai la personne que tu
croiseras c'est une invention totale
si je suis pas moi
alors qui je suis
non
quand tu étais je t'ai cherché partout
c'est ma femme tu es marié on va dire
qu'on est séparé
t'es pas ici en réalité étaient encore
bloqués à l'école attaché à un fauteuil
pendant du virtuel tire mon sens
quand brad illégal qu'il est
une meule faut vivre
dites moi ce que je sache qu'ils
voulaient récupérer ce que tu as dans le
cerveau
conseil le port de la ceinture